E
WILL BE COMING TO OUR BORDER
ILLEGALLY, PERHAPS IN THE NEXT
MONTH.
YESTERDAY SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
TO READ WHAT IS THE WORSENING
BORDER CONDITIONS IN THE YUMA
SECTOR IN ARIZONA WHERE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING
TO DO DAMAGE CONTROL TONIGHT
BECAUSE, GET THIS, ACCORDING TO
A REPORT, BORDER AGENTS CLEARED
OUT THE ONLY OVER LOW FACILITY
IN THE YUMA SECTOR HEAD OF
SENATOR GRAHAM'S VISIT.
SO ASK YOURSELF, WHY WAS THE
FACILITY ALL OF A SUDDEN CLEARED
OUT?
THE ANSWER SHOULD BE OBVIOUS, IT
IS CALLED ANOTHER BIDEN COVER-UP
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO
SEE IT JUST LIKE THEY DON'T WANT
CAMERAS IN THE OVERCROWDED CAGES
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC THAT
THEY BUILT.
WHERE DID THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
INSIDE THE FACILITY GO TO?
DID THEY GET COVID TESTER?
THE VACCINE MANDATE?
OR DO THEY DISPERSED TO THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY AND RELEASED INTO
THE INTERIOR OF THE U.S.?
DID THEY DO ANYTHING, IMPOSE ANY
OF THE HEALTH MANDATES THEY ARE
IMPOSING ON YOU ON THEM?
ANYWAY, THE BIDEN OPEN BORDERS
AGENDA, DOESN'T STOP THERE AS
SECRETARY MAYORKAS HAS ORDERED
I.C.E. TO STOP ANY DEPORTATION
RAID.
HERE WITH REACTION
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
HOW CONVENIENT THAT YOU ARE
HEADED TO GIVE AN HONEST REPORT
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE YUMA
SECTOR, AND THEY CLEANED
EVERYTHING OUT JUST BEFORE YOU
GOT THERE.
SOUNDS A LOT LIKE WHEN YOU,
SENATOR CRUZ AND OTHERS WENT TO
SEE THE BIDEN CAGES IN TEXAS.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I SAW.
THE BORDER PATROL WOULD LIKE ME
TO COME DOWN EVERY WEEK BECAUSE
THEY FINALLY GET SOMEONE TO HELP
THEM.
THE BORDER PATROL, MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE BORDER PATROL ARE BEING
ASKED TO DO THE IMPOSSIBLE.
AMERICAN PATRIOTS SAY THEY
DESERVE ALL OF OUR APPRECIATION
AND THANKS BUT THEY HAVE BEEN
ABANDONED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
5,000 PEOPLE IN THE FACILITY
MADE FOR 500 UNTIL I CAME.
WHEN I GOT THERE THERE WAS STILL
1,000 PER YEAR BETWEEN OCTOBER
OF 2020 AND OCTOBER OF THIS
YEAR, 2021, IN THE YUMA SECTOR
ALONE THERE HAS BEEN A 1300%
INCREASE IN ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
IN ALL OF 202018 PEOPLE WERE
APPREHENDED IN THE YUMA SECTOR.
AS OF THE WEEK I WENT THERE, A
COUPLE DAYS AGO, 114,000 PEOPLE
IN THE YUMA SECTOR ALONE.
WHAT YOU SEE IN TEXAS IS MOVING
TO ARIZONA, MY FRIEND.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS,
WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS, OR WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE, ALL
PREDICATED ON THE GREAT DOCUMENT
KNOWN AS OUR CONSTITUTION.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT ONLY NOT
ENFORCING THE LAW BUT HE IS
AIDING AND ABETTING LAWBREAKING
BY PROCESSING AND ITEM
REQUIRING -- THEY ARE REQUESTING
PEOPLE SHOW UP, NOT REQUIRING.
MY QUESTION IS DOES EVERY OTHER
AMERICAN GET TO PICK AND CHOOSE
WHAT LAWS THEY WANT TO OBEY AND
NOT OBEY?
>> IF YOU WERE REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY, SPREADING COVID.
IF YOU'RE TRAVELING FROM GERMANY
TO THE UNITED STATES YOU HAVE TO
BE VACCINATED AND HAVE A
NEGATIVE TEST.
114,000 PEOPLE COME INTO THE
YUMA SECTOR ALONE SINCE LAST
OCTOBER.
NOBODY'S BEING TESTED, NOBODY'S
BEING VACCINATED.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO DO THAT --
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE, ISN'T
THAT PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS?
>> YEAH, IT IS DANGEROUS.
WHAT I SAW THAT BOTHERS ME THE
MOST IS ANOTHER 9/11 IN THE
MAKING.
80 COUNTRIES THEY HAVE PICKED
PEOPLE UP FROM.
TWO TERRORISTS FROM YUMA THEY
CAUGHT JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
HOW EASY WOULD IT BE FOR
AL QAEDA OR ISIS TO LEAD OUT
AFGHANISTAN COME THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER TO BLEND IN WITH
THIS GROUP GRIFF WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
THE BORDER PATROL IS DOING THE
BEST THEY CAN BUT THEY TOLD ME
THAT THE LIKELIHOOD OF A
TERRORIST ATTACK COMING FROM OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER GROWS BY THE DAY
AND WHAT YOU SEE IN TEXAS IS
MOVING TO ARIZONA.
A 1300% INCREASE IN ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS IN THE YUMA SECTOR IN
THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
WHY?
WE CHANGED THE ROMAINE AND
MEXICO POLICY.
WHAT MALLORCA'S DID TODAY IS
GOING TO BE ANOTHER INCENTIVE
FOR PEOPLE TO COME.
THE WORD IS OUT, YOU COME, YOU
CLAIM ASYLUM, YOU NEVER LEAVE,
THE POLICY CHOICES OF BIDEN OR E
ALL OVER THE WORLD NOW -- ALONE
HEADED TO CONNECTICUT WEARING
DESIGNER CLOTHING GUCCI BAGS.
PEOPLE SEE IN OPEN AMERICA,
THEY'VE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF US
AND IT WON'T BE LONG BEFORE
TERRORIST GETS AN.
>> Sean: UNRELATED QUESTION,
THE LAST WEEK AND TWO MONTHS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WAS UNITED IN
SAYING THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
HELP THE DEMOCRATS, NOT INVOLVED
IN THE BUDGET AND PUSHED AWAY.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HELP RAISE
THE DEBT CEILING.
THEN LAST TUESDAY, ONE WEEK AGO
TODAY MITCH McCONNELL FOLDED.
YOUR WORDS.
WE FOLDED.
WHY DID 11 REPUBLICANS FOR TWO
MONTHS TO HELP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THEY WERE GOING TO DO ONE
THING AND DO ANOTHER?
WHY DIDN'T THEY KEEP THEIR WORD?
>> WE SHOULD HAVE, WE GOT
OURSELVES IN A BOX BUT WE SENT A
LETTER TO PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYING
WE WILL NEVER DO THIS AGAIN.
THAT IS ENCOURAGING TO ME.
>> Sean: BUT WHY SHOULD WE
BELIEVE HIM THIS TIME?
FOR TWO MONTHS, THE WHOLE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WAS SAYING WE
ARE UNITED.
>> YEAH, I FEEL CONFIDENT WE ARE
NOT GOING TO DO THIS AGAIN AND
IF WE DO THIS AGAIN WE ARE GOING
TO SHOOT OURSELVES IN THE HEAD
POLITICALLY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS RUNNING
THIS COUNTRY, THEY NEED TO STAND
STRONG.
I WENT TO THE BORDER AND SARAH
WENT WITH ME.
WHAT I SAW BROKE MY HEART AND I
HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE WORRIED
ABOUT A TERRORIST ATTACK THAN I
AM RIGHT NOW.
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE BORDER
PATROL HAVE BEEN ABANDONED BY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
DO YOU SEE A PLAN TO CHANGE
THIS?
THEY SAID NO.
>> Sean: DO ME A FAVOR, YOU
MIGHT WANT TO ASK JOE IF YOU
EVER GET TO SEE HIM COME AND
VISIT HIM IN DELAWARE, YOU MIGHT
WANT TO ASK WHAT HIS PLA